with a salary of more than 84 000 pounds
MPS earn around three times the UK
average they can expense the cost of
running an office employing staff having
a home in London and their constituency
and traveling to and from Parliament but
some choose to earn more sometimes a lot
more by taking on a second job
[Music]
five biggest earners in the House of
Commons have each declared well over
half a million pounds from second jobs
since the last election that's on top of
their MP salaries with former prime
minister Theresa May topping the list
and her successor Boris Johnson shooting
up the ranks to third after earning over
a million pounds since he stepped down
last autumn
[Music]
a scandal erupted last year after it was
found that the senior conservative MP
Owen Patterson had lobbied ministers on
behalf of two private companies for
which he was employed as a consultant
the story reignited a debate about
second jobs with new and Tighter rules
being introduced do you believe that
Owen Patterson broke the rules yes yes
or no yes MPS will no longer be able to
take jobs advising companies on
political strategy or parliamentary
procedure they'll also need to sign a
contract with the providers of those
second jobs making it clear that paid
lobbying is not part of their employment
[Music]
until a generation or two ago a lot of
MPS had a professional job outside
Parliament as a lawyer doctor or
journalist for example it was felt to be
important that they had experience of
the world outside Parliament but second
jobs have become controversial there are
no limits on how many hours MPS spend
doing them or how much they can earn the
MP's code of conduct said the rules are
intended to avoid any suggestion that
the parliamentary or policy agenda can
be set by an outside individual or
organization making payments to a member
labor say if they win office they would
ban most second jobs with some limited
exceptions but for now MPS continue to
take them on